[Music]
debbie ryan played a pageant queen on
insatiable
no i'd rather have revenge and now she's
proving she is a
queen in real life i mean duh but
specifically i'm talking about on tik
[Music]
tok
that's the tick tock video that got the
27 year old former disney channel star
trending on twitter monday night paying
homage to some of her memorable roles
from the past
the theme fashion week but make it
debbie ryan
i'm an actor so these things are fun
yeah there's debbie as
jessie as bailey on the suite life on
deck
and as patty on insatiable but guys the
grand finale
is the best freaking part
[Music]
in case you need a refresher that's
debbie dressed as her character
tara in the 2012 disney channel original
movie radio rebel
for whatever reason the movie recently
went viral on social media
because of this scene which is now a
hilarious meme
tara swoops her hair out of her face and
makes flirty eye contact with the singer
on stage
so not only is debbie in on the joke
she's totally still got it i mean those
facial expressions
come on
when it comes to former disney stars
totally owning tick tock
debbie is not alone i feel very blessed
ashley tisdale has racked up over 5
million followers
for posting all sorts of amazing videos
dancing
lip dubbing iconic scenes from keeping
up with the kardashians
take off my boots oh my god my boot not
my
foot do i look fat just like 20 pounds
overweight you're
and even teaming up with her bestie and
fellow high school musical star vanessa
hudgins
to give us this gift
[Music]
i just feel like it's such a great way
to be a creator in your own life of like
what you want to put out there
i love social media